[Music]
you've lived a life dominated by doubt
and fear how do you step into bravery I
think if you don't have anything on your
calendar that that scares you that makes
you nervous you actually hate your life
also just attack fear wherever you see
it rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message step aggressively
towards your fear over to you Jocko
willing also if you want to know what
Jocko will like and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below people want to
know how to stop the laziness and they
will know how to stop the
procrastination you've lived a life
dominated by doubt and fear how do you
step into bravery step that's how you
step into bravery step take the step
step aggressively toward your fear and
that that step towards your fear is the
step into bravery because we're we're
scared of what we don't know and there's
only one way to learn and to know and
that is to confront that fear you have
to step you have to go and this simple
action this simple attitude it answers
so many questions so many questions how
do you get to the gym every day you step
you go how do you how do you change your
diet you step you go how do you overcome
fear of failure fear of success or or
fear of fear itself
you step and how do you face the fear of
the unknown your step don't wait anymore
don't think anymore don't plan anymore
don't contemplate anymore don't make any
more excuses or justifications don't
rationalize anything else no no and no
instead be aggressive take action now
and what is the first action that you
need to take what's the first step you
need to take the first step you need to
take is just that step you need to give
yourself permission to fail you need to
give yourself permission to make
mistakes you need to give yourself
permission to lose why because failing
and knowing is better than not knowing
and regretting and you won't figure this
out sitting on the couch you cannot
think your way through this you need to
step so look at the tour that I have
coming up we're hitting 23 cities in 90
days and I'm afraid I'm afraid of going
and putting on these events and it
failing and nobody's showing up I'm
afraid not that I won't be able to bring
value because I think even if one person
shows up we're gonna have the greatest
time of all time and I'm gonna move that
person they will shift whoever shows up
is in for a life-changing experience a
thousand percent but I'm still afraid
that people won't show up I'm afraid
that I'm gonna disappoint people
that's my greatest fear is letting
somebody down it ends up being a
strength in that I over deliver so I
always bring so much I don't let people
down but that's my fear
and as a result I'll do things that play
small compared to what I should be doing
the idea for the paid tour came when I
went to New York and I did a fan meetup
at a New York coffee shop and we had too
many people show up and people couldn't
hear me and people didn't have seats and
it's a great problem to have I went
actually feeling great from that like
man this is amazing we had too many
people the coffee shop it's awesome and
then I went to go see my agent for
dinner right away afterwards and he says
you suck you're playing too small you
know you're afraid to take a bigger risk
you should be charging for these things
and the idea of of charging for 23
different events consecutively in 90
days and trying to sell those tickets
freaked me out
I was afraid and so I had to do it like
how do you conquer the fear you step and
we may sell out some events and we may
have one person show up to each event
I'm gonna bring my best regardless but
it's stepping into that fear it's
feeling the fear and stepping into it
it's not don't be afraid I think if you
don't have anything on your calendar
that scares you that makes you nervous
you actually hate your life like if
you're playing life so safe that there's
nothing on your calendar that scares you
you have a pretty boring life you think
your life is boring not me
you you don't like your life if you're
not stretching if you're not growing if
you're not doing something that is
different and that makes you a little
bit scared or nervous and so everything
great is on the other side of that fear
everything that you want all the goals
that you have for yourself are on the
other side of your convenience and your
fear it doesn't mean that it's gonna
work out doesn't mean that stepping into
the fear means that it's absolutely 100%
gonna work out I may not but every time
you step into the fear every time you do
the thing that you're afraid of you get
closer to hitting your goal not stepping
in staying where you are sitting on the
couch planning all these alternatives
means you stay where you are
means you're never gonna hit your goals
and so step into the fear
even if you don't care about that thing
stepping into the fear just for the sake
of developing the identity that I am the
kind of person who steps into fear that
when faced with fear you have two
options when faced with fear do you rise
to the occasion and step into it or when
faced with fear do you go home and cry
do you take the safe route do you take
the cowardly route because that's a
really important moment because if
you're faced with fear and your history
has always been I shy away that's the
identity you built for yourself and
that's dangerous you want to build the
identity that I'm the person who steps
into it that I'm the person who does not
want to live with regret that I can
handle the failure I can handle it not
working out I can handle potential
embarrassment but I can't handle not
knowing and living the rest of my life
with regret so I'm gonna give you the
three-step process
to step into the next biggest fear in
your life and start making some major
momentum happen for you number one
what's the next big step that you need
to take in your life for business what's
the next big step like what is the thing
that you need to do that scares you it's
a big step when you think about it wow
that's too big what is that next big
step that when you're feeling bold and
confident when you've gone to a vent or
watched a video you feel inspired so
yeah I could do that I deserve to do
that I have the skills I have the talent
I should be playing at that level and
I'm frustrated that I'm still here what
is that next big step for you step
number two what are the logical reasons
that you're telling yourself why you
can't get it we always have this story I
can't do it because I'm not good enough
yet because I don't have the resources
yet because this president's and power
because whatever there's always some
reason what are the logical reasons that
are based in fact you not having the
right education can be a limitation if
the story was totally illogical then
it's easy to poke holes in it but
they're based in facts these stories
these logical reasons why you won't win
are based on something that is actually
true so what are the logical reasons why
you can't go off and accomplish your big
goal that we set in question number one
and step number three what is the real
fear that's underneath it all and how
you gonna step into it underneath all
those logical reasons this fear
really if you get honest with yourself
you keep asking yourself why why am I
not willing to do it other people have
done it other people with less resources
with less talent with less skill with
less ability with less connections
they've done it they've done it
you haven't why what are you so afraid
of what's that big fear that you are so
afraid of let's put the logical reasons
to the side they're based in reality
they're based in facts but it's not the
actual truth why you are not making more
progress what's to fear and then what
are you gonna do today to step into it
now I've got a really special bonus clip
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question today I want to
know what is that big fear you're facing
and what are you gonna do today to step
into it let me know put in the comments
below let's get some momentum together I
want to see it
also just a tack fear wherever you see
it even when it's trivial even when it's
some kind of we were just before that
before we got on here we talked about
the fear of the number 13 true got
Rococo be alike if you're afraid of 13
you know what you need to do you need to
put 13s all over your house
you know you need to like sit in 13s you
need to go to the 13th demand to be on
the 13th floor of every hotel in every
airplane because you got to get over
that because that is telling yourself
that there's something irrational that
should control you and if you believe
there's something that's irrational that
should control you that will apply
universally so wherever you find fear
specifically that's out of balance with
actual danger like I'm not saying touch
a hot stove or put your hand in a
rattlesnake cage like there's danger
there that's not fear but 13 no danger
you know that's not real
so go collapse that if there's a fear of
crickets like I have or a fear of like
whatever it is collapse fear wherever
you see it and that specific collapse
will help with the universal collapse of
fear in general if you want more jakka
willing check out the jakka will link
motivation video i made the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there where does discipline
[Music]